warning this video contains scenes of
extreme violence which is awesome hello
everybody my name is markiplier and
welcome to let's play boom Jim what the
hell is that okay yeah so brutal doom is
a modification of the original doom but
you can see there are some changes that
have been made the pistol is not a
machine gun I can jump I can Crouch I
can mouse aim and there is more blood
than a stadium full of Satanist setup
baby killing convention I'm not good
with those sort of things I'm not very
spontaneous guy but anyway this this is
quite honestly the most awesome
modification or game I have ever played
in my entire life there is so much blood
everywhere
just wow just explosions oh it's
incredible and awesome it the imps have
different mechanics in everything just
works to extraordinary fashion gouts of
blood I can actually jump which is a
really nice feature good yeah and just
like unbelievably why did I did not mean
to switch that Wow
yeah I mean I thought shouldn't be so
careless oh and these guys can do oh oh
no his arm got cut off ha get out here
it's also a little more intense they do
a lot more monster spawns and all sorts
of stuff like that
either way oh no it's just freaking
awesome but I don't expect a lot from
this playthrough I'm not gonna like do a
full let's play of doom ya know gonna
turn your back rah rah ham
I'm just gonna be playing this to show
you guys how frickin awesome it is which
it is if you couldn't tell already I'm a
fan of doom I remember way back like in
1995
it is like the faller father of
first-person shooters by the way if you
didn't already know like it's kind of
the one that spawned the idea for a
first whoa that's a [ __ ] cyber team
oh god oh god oh god I'm in the lava I'm
in the lava thank you for the powerup oh
I saw that yep Wow
I'm good I'm good hello boom yeah so
Doom is like the father of all
first-person shooter it is the
granddaddy and know that there's still a
thriving community base ground it off
bring it on [ __ ] Wow hey don't bring it
on that hard wait where am I where the
hell did I get blown off - damn why is
it cyberdemon right there that kind of
hampers my ability to kick you in the
balls
oh hello whoa I blowed the cyberdemon up
like really I tell a frag him that was
it that's the name of the the thing when
you teleport into someone that's called
tella fragging and it killed them good
good
lordy Lordy loo this is like probably
the coolest thing I've ever played in a
long time so excuse me while I no doubt
for a bit because I mean come on
for those of you who remember doom this
this this is awesome I mean come on
could you ask for anything more
it's doomed for God's sake the original
granddaddy back when I played it on das
does anybody else y'all I'm not all by
any means but I like I remember I
remember playing it too freaking out
whoa hello meow holy crap mwah Oh suck
it down I just got the invulnerability
power up by the way what the hell is
this level
okay I'm starting to think that this
this campaigns that I'm playing it's
called by thy soul consumed I don't know
some fancy name like that but either way
it's obviously not part of the original
doom that I played I've no idea what
it's from originally but it's pretty
pretty awesome campaign ooh
oh it's time oh is time come on bring it
[ __ ]
bring it [ __ ] oh what's that you want
to live too bad another one to draw I am
the greatest there ever was I'm gonna
ran out I guess
but the giant bouts of blood off your
guts are spilling out I'll take care of
that for you bomb blood every whichaway
that's why there was a disclaimer at the
beginning of this video yeah bleep epic
I'm so great also if anyone wants to
like look up something fun
check out the calculation for June guys
that's the main catch that you guys got
name check out the calculation for his
actual running speed this guy this it
proves like dude guys like the biggest
badass in the entirety of gaming history
just because he can carry about six
weapons he can sprint and like 120 miles
per hour that's how fast this guy's
sprinting in terms of the map units he's
just like overall the biggest badass to
ever walk the face of gaming to ever
grace us with his incredible team
presence before there was the Master
Chief with all his power on earth before
there was I don't know who else Gordon
Freeman with his power suit there was
doom guy and his regular ordinary
soldier combat armor and ridiculous
demon infused awesomeness I don't know
why I'm going I've got a lot at the
moment I don't even care I don't even
care if there was an objective well I
care about more people to explode well
hello man oh good golly oh hell yeah
Wow that is so horrific Oh get over no
no I wanna talk with you for a second oh
whoops whoops
I shouldn't have confronted that guy
with a chainsaw just gonna throw that
out there right now
first I'm just gonna run for the exit
here do these pardon me with that let
your brow
Jimmy haha no you guys are gonna get it
[ __ ] ow well I I hope you guys can see
more than just with gigantic gouts of
blood squirting every whichaway damn it
I need more pistol ammo bro Brown
shotguns good enough shotgun is more
than good enough I love I love
everything that they've done with it
they're just everything is so so
amazingly perfectly brutal in every way
[ __ ] hence why it's called brutal doom
fisticuffs time grip laptop gummy our
[ __ ] get down on the ground wish wish
wish wish wish wish yeah plasma rifle
get drag you [ __ ] okay I got the red
key I just don't know where to put it
about time I got something for all these
plasma rounds I've been checking up Oh
Oh almost had help fudge fudge no no no
no no no oh come on
bollocks dragon group do they yeah it's
much harder I'm not even on that heart
of a difficulty and I'm getting my ass
handed to me like a lot it's kind of
ridiculous actually OOP huh oh I [ __ ]
that one up oh I caught it with my face
all right yeah like I said don't expect
like me to do a full playground just
playing this just wanted to show you
guys like this this is why this is why
the modding community is great and why
modern game makers should really get
their act together and let the people
change their game because then really
cool stuff like this happens and this is
probably the coolest [ __ ] I've ever seen
in my time
but that's enough of that I'm just gonna
shut up for a bit and let us let the
flood speak for itself
bro
haha
how'd that guy get set on Fiverr
hahahaha I need help
like now I'm not doing well hang on hang
on hang on I got a blue key now and just
need these to find out what to do oh
crap oh crap oh crap oh crap oh oh hi
I'm gonna stop digging around get my
actual act together and really give this
a solid play
I need to get all these books because
this gun is obviously superior than
the frickin shotgun
[Laughter]
did you get
oh man you know I've been I haven't
played this like and I knew about it a
long time ago I just did not spend the
time to actually play the game I mean
and I regret all of you should played if
you own a copy of doom what the hell was
he doing there that's like my ally I
think whoops I shoot my allies my bad
bro
my bad brah okay here we go bow
oh there you all were hiding oh man shut
up we all got problems okay go back in
here I'm just starting to get my pro
skills back not that Pro apparently not
very Pro at all actually just starting
to get pro skills back there we are top
bow bow shut up take your lumps like a
man Twinkletoes yep
oh I actually have full health let's not
squander it suck on fact nope
fail
yep well I mean I don't really have much
love to say I mean I've said everything
that needs to be said
I played the this game is working
amazing in every way I know where the
Red Door is I know where the red doors
the red doors down here huh there we go
and then I think I saw the blue door
whoops whoa hi hi hi what did I do all
of you die please get melted and have a
nice day
haha holy crap I want to shoot someone
with the BFG I think I distinctly
remember picking that up at some point
down the road I do holy how why have I
not use this I'm gonna use this next
game oh yeah I only got a few more
minutes I don't want to stop I don't
want to stop this is just freaking
awesome I only have four percent of this
secrets oops my bad
hahaha not enough I need more anymore
need more
we require more verse pain gas and I
require people now need more I need to
finish this off with something really
big come on
so come on bring it on [ __ ] what do
you got what do you got
bring it I want to destroy you finish
this off with a shower of blood the
likes of which that has never been seen
oh hello gimme gimme thank you I missed
the other one
whoops come on where are all the peeps I
want to destroy must destroy here we go
No
not good enough oh the exit look can I
start fine [ __ ] it [ __ ] it I'm doing it
Oh [ __ ] bar go how do you like me now
ah ho hey ho okay I can't get through
there that one this one Wow okay so
anyway that it'll about wrap it up for
me here hope you enjoyed this little
brutal session of gaming here just to
show you what awesome things lines
stored that you can just find around the
corner if you just look for games and
stuff like this you'll find some of the
coolest stuff people not companies
people make the coolest things and I'm
always willing to support them so go
check it out all the necessary
information is in the description below
thank you guys so much for watching hope
you enjoyed it and as always I will see
you bye bye
[Music]